Thanks so what was like working with
Rachel Weisz as a romantic partner on
this film I mean it was it was wonderful
I you know I've been such a fan of hers
for such a long time we actually worked
together once before but it was only for
a day so got a little bit more time
together this time which was amazing I
am just I'm such an admirer of her so
and you know she she just brings so much
depth in such an effortless way you know
there's so much going on behind her eyes
and you really just have to be present
with her and like take her lead and
you'll be fine so I kind of did that and
yeah I think I feel like we really took
care of each other we had each other's
backs you know not that we had to battle
anything because our director was always
on the same side as well so it was such
a wonderful wonderful film to shoot how
is your town so did you give her I mean
stranger tiff but did you give her any
tips for hanging out to go eat
I did I did try to encourage them to
come over to the Moodle noodle bar at
Momofuku today so yeah I got Sebastian
over and now I think he's a true
believer so yeah